er kämpft für die cdu in duisburg
marxloh grün gelb rot deniz güner gegen
die am platze die st und da ist
kandidatin kann ich nicht mehr über rot
gehen ja ja genau sie nennen ihn den
sheriff von duisburg marxloh ein türke
räumt auf
die deutschen gesetze
ja marxloh
schön habt das hier ist jetzt bei der
cdu der lieblings türke
der einzige der einzige arzt heinz wir
auch der einzige der kandidiert die cdu
hat ja im bundestag nur vier prozent
migrationshintergrund die a stehe aber
zu immer größeren 4 prozent 7 prozent
was macht die eigentlich besser das ist
das sehr gute frage was machen wir nicht
so gut würde ich fragen nicht so gut wie
wir müssen wenn du mich fragst müssen
wir eine quote einführen weil wir
kriegen das alleinige button quoten
türke
[Musik]
acht lampen geschäfte 40 trinkhallen 230
restaurants 500 freunde und 60 wackler
war später
erklärt sich der aufstieg von deniz
güner wir haben immer gesagt spd ist
arbeiterpartei ja die stehen für die
ausländer immer aber ich glaube jetzt
hat sich das etwas geändert
haben sich den hühner kommt spricht mit
uns ja okay wir würden auch gerne
türkische abgeordnete türkischer kanzler
türkische fischer warum gegen bereich
warum nicht wahlkampfveranstaltungen der
nrw-cdu in wattenscheid
da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob ihr die
irgend jemand kennt wir sind mit dem
herrn unterwegs zu welcher partei würden
sie ihn einordnen welche partei
fahrzeug ich da ja
was machen sie denn ich kandidiere für
die cdu im westen übernommen für den
landtag
und wir werden jetzt in duisburg auch
aufräumen schlimmste ableger der migrant
muss nicht mehr aufholen sondern er kann
teilhaben ja gut
ich bin bademeister ist die cdu eine
partei des alten weißen mannes sie ist
eine partei des weißen mannes aber auch
vom fluren jung und kopf richtig und
würden sie einen prototyp alter weißer
mann beschreiben
also menschen mit migrationsgeschichte
bei der cdu was wo ist da der knackpunkt
warum scheitert es nicht
ich bitte sie dir einsetzen weil sowie
viele wie viele fallen jetzt spontan
einen menschen mit muslimischem
migrationshintergrund
drei namen reichen
ein name reicht ja bühler
ja das ist wirklich womit die
bekannteste zu müssen noch nicht mal der
cdu oder ich habe den eindruck dass ich
bin single abschicken dann steigst du
denn mit dem morgen ab jetzt denkt der
züge der kann hier befehle geben ich
glaube so wird das ist eine bitte ich
kann dir ja selbst für die cdu und die
spd in den landtag und bin gerade dabei
den laden aufzuräumen richtig sehr gut
weil die hat man hier hat man zu den
eindruck du bist schon ein bisschen der
chef vom lachs oder
aufräumen du bist du der hay deutsche
gesetze auf duisburger straße hast du
ein problem damit aber anders überlegt
schweren verstössen damit du dich mehr
mögen
ich bin ja eigentlich veganer
programm ist ein bisschen ehrlicher
so kinder ich hoffe die kamera läuft
denn ich halte nicht an abonniert den
kanal hier danke euer gernot hassknecht
so ich gehe wieder nach hause
schönen feierabend jürgen zschau